prior to the ball game tonight virtually
alec balm was honored as the phillies
recipient of the roberto clemente award
the award one player is chosen from each
organization around baseball and then
voting will begin to see who the overall
winner is and he is the nominee for this
year's roberto clemente award
congratulations to alec baum
he has done some amazing work through
his foundation and his family through
his church as well
the young man gets it absolutely gets it
on every single level
andrew mccutchen is wearing the number
21 tonight as he did last year around
baseball there are certain players that
have asked to and have been honored to
wear the number 21 on this uh this day
honoring roberto clemente his ranger
ninth start of the year six and four
an era of 1.38
he has a 1.670 ra as a starting pitcher
and during his eight starts he's gone 37
and two-thirds innings i've just been
enjoying watching how he's
made adjustments and
he hammers that one to left and that one
will take a bounce
and hop off the wall schwindel into
second
they got that out front and it's a
double
[Applause]
it's a fastball to his liking
does not come around it stays through it
been entirely too many extra base hits
down that left field line already in
this series tom
swing and a foul tip net holds on two
outs here in the first
suarez 93 that was talent away
two strikeouts he leaves one in scoring
position alec mills the reliable starter
out on the mound sinker four-seam change
of slider curveball
in there got him
and herrera doesn't complain to adrian
johnson one up one down real good pitch
when you get a hitter looking out over
the plate
i mean this pitch wasn't even
necessarily inside and it just
completely locked him up
oh he got him
curveball swinging a miss struck him out
i need somebody to remind me that guy in
the box especially a guy like him is
gonna beat me to the base
the strikeout mills razor sharp here in
the early going
0-2
swing and a miss struck him out
and how about mccutcheon six up six down
four punch outs
that's a base it up the middle for
freddie galvez
first hit of the night for the phils
first base runner
and it comes leading off the bottom of
the third
and that bunch toward thirds good bud
duffy can't handle it that's what i'm
talking about
is it the best bun no it's a little firm
you know what you put pressure on the
defense
duffy can't come up with it
maybe a little peekaboo there tom
on the ground to the right side and it
just saved him a run
mills
in the air left field towering fly ball
wisdom makes the grab on the track and
segura just missed it and mills gets out
of the jam
going in there again
that is a fair ball as it skips just
inside the line hits the half wall and
harper is into second base easily with
the lead off double 34 doubles for bryce
harper he's now hitting 11 consecutive
games
jt not deep center field
and half he can't get there he lets it
bounce the throw to third not in time
now they've got jt and there's nobody
covering first so it's no big deal
[Applause]
on the ground body spins they get one
there
and they get two there well done
run comes in phillies take the lead but
that's good defense out there here's
freddie galvez who had a base hit his
last time up two balls no strikes to
galvez
galvez hits it well deep to right field
forget about that one it is gone
off the bottom part of the auxiliary
scoreboard it's a two run home run and
the phillies lead it three to nothing
this is sweet pitching coach comes out
and say hey we got to get back in the
swing of things no pun intended
that is the thing of beauty
duffy climbs in suarez been good
rip down the left side hooking and
that's a fair ball and it'll hop off the
wall duffy with his second hit of the
night
and a man immediately into scoring
position
that's just confidence matt duffy
knowing he's going to probably get a
pitch to hit right in the middle of the
play to hang and change up
with no outs it'll bring up frank
schwendall
drilled right field this one back it's
got a chance gone
and frank the tank unloads and they're
loving it here at citizens bank park
and just like that the cubs
are within a run every direction it
doesn't matter he hits it hard
[Applause]
line drive out towards center half on
the road it's passed him over his head
it's going to the wall
and ranger to second base
it's his second double
[Applause]
oh yeah
i'll get you some ranger
and a looper or into right center field
of base since juarez around third
heading for home the throw is cut off an
rbi single it's four to two
phil's on top
robinson torino's batting
drilled in the air left field that one
back mccutcheon at the wall and we are
tied
robinson chirinos
and it's
four
didn't sound great off the bat
adrino's gets enough of it obviously
jt romuto will lead off it's a 4-4 ball
game
the balls hit well out to right field
off toward the wall it's gone
on offense and field home run for jt the
philly's spinning around
they retake the lead it's five to four
jt has a three hit nights
first pitch swinging
[Applause]
what a short compact strong swing
here's the first pitch to matt duffy
drilled in the air deep left field this
ball's got a chance
gone
a game-tying home run by matt duffy
first pitch from ian kennedy
just like the first pitch in the bottom
of the eighth inning from cody hoyer was
drilled for a home run
this one is smacked by matt duffy over
the wall and left his third hit of the
night
and this ball game is tied at five
tattoos this ball ties it up
and the bullpen struggles for the
phillies continue you two pitch kevin
sharply a base in it to right center
field
andrew is aboard he'll put the brakes on
the phillies have the lead off hitter
aboard here in the ninth inning
ponyx squares
bunsen towards first that's the beauty
of the bunk but he's going to get the
run
into scoring position
and the o2 back toward the middle
knocked down by mcgill
that goes to third
but now the fills are down to their last
out
with the winning run over at third here
in the bottom of the ninth inning
off the glove
of gerino snap's going to score
how about that the phillies have one at
the bottom of the ninth inning
as the ball went off chirinos and rolled
toward the cubs dug out knapp just
strolled on home
a 6-5 victory in the craziest of ways